per adulti ragazzi mi avete questo video
sono parigi oggi sono con giulia la
buona giulia che è da una vita che non
facciamo un video insiemi rotta sul mio
canale o degli occhiali perché mi ha
rimproverato che sto troppo al computer
e quindi mi ha detto di mettere gli
occhiali a riposo e così sta facendo
veramente il video con gli occhiali sì
sto facendo video perché mi ha detto lei
incredi allora giulia se non la
conoscete noi ci siamo conosciuti tempo
fa in una maniera molto molto simpatica
che questa è questa qua la maniera di
spostare che ci stanno a limonare sti
due allora siccome poi è nata da questo
bacio un'amicizia incredibile indire di
bill abbiamo deciso di fare un altro
video insieme allo ragazzi tu oggi mi
hai preparato una sfilza di commenti che
hai trovato sotto sempre bene di gente
che la vita non gli va sempre male
allora fammi vedere che c'è niente
prende il telefono fammi vedere ma che
poi il pezzo parla del fatto che ci sono
un sacco di sfide le cose che ci
succedono per tutto il giorno e poi dice
famose la via beni famosa via alberti
famose la pia bene speriamo come come se
la possono via ben armati li leggo pure
lui non li sanno gli hano io non so
niente leila sigg.ri nati i commenti di
sempre alcuni commenti sempre bene i
piedi peggiori anche in a ma anche
quelli più non senza ok siamo da uno
leggero bello l'acqua team è la cosa più
kringe del mo allora non sa cosa vuol
dire grigie ma allora io mi arrabbio non
so che cosa tutti presenti adesso ti
guarda che è successo mettere questo il
segno degli occhiali la parola kringe
nel 2019 non vuol dire più di massa la e
16 17 aveva senso klinge e che cos'era
era quando tu vedevi una roba dove una
persona ci credi in quello che sta
facendo ma ti crea una situazione di
disagio come green già vano tanto
hebrang perché non riuscivo a vedere
tipo quinti di ciò che fanno i branchi
non riesca vederli perché non riesco a
vedere la persona che si fa prendere per
si fa breakkare non riesco a guardare a
mi crea del kringe questo è il clima
khrin giardini mi urta più non
innervosire tanto ti dice ma chiesta
stacca questa gag ata in poche parole
però non c'é però una persona che lo sta
facendo ci sta credendo che adesso non è
più così a braccio adesso non è più così
kringe non è più bisogna ormai dicono
tutti che ormai dicono perché tutti
riconosciuti in qualsiasi cosa non credo
tu sia arrivata dove sei ora grazie alle
tue doti vocali
non credo sia musica questa no io e
sicuramente è arrivata così non solo
grazie alla voce ma anche grazie capelli
ma quello che noi diciamo che spavaldi
una cosa carina di tipo anche grazie che
ne so il suo esteri timpano quello nov i
capelli neri capelli aiutano tanto oltre
che canti bene secondo me quindi come ti
consigliamo anche nel tuo caso i capelli
tuoi era comunque avere tanti capelli e
capitan reati ancora meglio aiuta ad
arrivare a cantare se avete cantare
fatevi capelli infatti ho rubato il
telefono a lorenzo favi j ciao quando
stavo per fare quello futuro non penso
vabbè non guardare i messaggi che voglio
ma in tendenza si sia arrivata perché
avete strapagato o cosa video scabroso e
canzone per bimbi
ah già ma you tube per bimbi scusa
aspetta magari sport con sony si può
pagare per finire intende detto sì sì lo
sapevo nemmeno storia no ma adesso metti
momento 2 minuto 2 17 mettiamo il minor
2d momento feticista fa onore maschietto
non fatto se felici però dico sommati
letto è che ne so dove 17 momento più di
ci sta ma da giulia ma che sci ma metti
de decili di tacere
ballo ecco perché è stata infatti c'è
delle casse un po inutili stupito perché
perché questi sono gli scaldamuscoli
anni ottanta ai pensavo fosse fossero
calze senza la calza se gli
scaldamuscoli telefono che non chiama è
un po strano però va beh
bella comunque mi piace la tattica ma si
fa è perché quello è una città anni 80
la canzone vendute le sonorità anni 80 o
questo o quel momento feticista è fatto
scusa dici che ti mangi tutto quel fatto
di quattro morti che non so che cosa
vuol dire allora come è possibile che
sei così magra perché in una canzone
dico che mi mangio la pizza in quattro
morti perché va in palestra perché vado
in palestra ma è anche costituzione ma
che io io sono per costituzione sono
state di tipo a ma pure di mangia
carbonia porte del tipo a kabul meno ma
io pure
mancava team barese semo maggiori ma
rimani momagri e una gli ha risposto
pure io mangio tipo 4 che bubi il kebab
al giorno e sono stecchino 5 mecca
settimane ogni giorno e chiederemo di ha
pure questo sia giunto al cosa di magna
che a roma
ste cose si vedono tutti i giorni cioè
tutti mangiano è la maggior parte su
tutti i magri a magnano cominci pali dc
denutriti da 150 anni ma alla fine è
sempre tutto bene no sempre bene magnate
che sarebbe bene i magnati papa che
ridere la sua faccia posso fare tutto
scritto in maiuscolo non riesco a
leggere perché è kringe magi la pena
stare un po vj
ecco è che sa compagni affrontiamo
questo disco allora ars idea
hai dominato allora come sta storia
disponiamo così comunque allora in quel
momento sono un bel momento per me sono
un bel momento di move in tv non solo
stessa un momento quanto nipote dice sì
mi sono divertito simpatico bruciatore
lorenzi e allora è stato un bel momento
per alien ci siamo divertiti divertiti
cioè un limone valiente ma io so
caliente lo studio nel senso ti sei
divertita e hai trovato una persona che
sta a baciare di ci dai
ma vigenza baciare la sera basta questo
lo devo lo devo dire lo devo ammettere a
baciare quindi tutte voi che desiderate
le labbra di fa vj tutte voi che
desiderate l'ep labbra di fa vj posso
dirvi che fa vigenza baciare sì questo è
che allora gli ho detto che sei bravo ti
ho detto che chris ma l'ex ammetti la
canzone d'amore
alexia la stazione e canzoni d'amore da
amazon music
[Musica]
mengoni alexa basta alexa alexa.com
voglio bene non trovo la risposta nato a
benevento non c'è risposta
vabbè comunque per il resto sempre bene
era sempre bene i dislike obbligatorio
non manca mai la mia mi chiede sempre
così piace campa toglietelo finiti caso
finì tutto qua mamma mia quanto sono
scesi di qualità che una volta erano
bravini ma mai malta eravate più cattivi
ma non c'è più la passione nell'incubo
quell'odio c'è più quell odio perché
hanno capito secondo me hanno capito nel
tempo che facevano solo più del bene
agli all'influenza barra cantante barra
youtuber che e quindi hanno detto male e
basta
allora ecco se no un altro ma solo io
sono un pessimista di bijoux io ti adoro
sei bella sei bona ma questa della
potevi risparmiare il testo è iper
demenziale la musica e ripetitivo e
fastidiosa ragazze se non volete più
scovare si ascolta tenuto anche un
ragazzo ragazzi se non volete più
scovare ascoltato loro anche una ragazza
io a me non me frega se che abbassa che
cisco
[Musica]